[Musica]
nel 2003 avevo 20 anni ed ero un giovane
studente di economia all'università di
macerata al tempo l'iphone non esisteva
sarebbe arrivato solo nel 2007 e non
c'erano up per ogni cosa come oggi una
bella scocciatura per noi giovani
universitari era che per orientarci tra
lezioni ed esami dovevamo barcamenarsi
fra visi appeso in bacheca e
aggiornamenti captati in corridoio no
non c'era un app che ti notificasse
cambi degli orari delle lezioni eventi
importanti o scadenze da ricordare tutto
lavoro di fosforo e perspicacia al tempo
oltre a frequentare l'università
studiavo anche direzione d'orchestra in
conservatorio forse sarà stato per
questo che un giorno decisi di cambiare
musica
tra i miei compagni di università c'era
pierluigi un vero drago dell'informatica
per luigi aveva una strana empatia con i
pc e sapeva programmare alla grande così
lo incalza i me lo ricordo benissimo
davanti a un caffè un giorno mi chiesi e
se le cose potessero funzionare in un
altro modo
ipotizziamo di creare una bacheca
virtuale un grande monitor lcd che
aggiornasse gli studenti in tempo reale
su tutte le informazioni più importanti
relative alla quotidianità universitaria
banale pensarla oggi forse sì allora era
semplicemente un opzione inesistente
creiamo un prototipo e lo presentano la
presidenza che con nostro grande stupore
accetta l'idea parti un progetto
studentesco in cui coinvolgeremo una
ventina di altri ragazzi e in poche
settimane quella bacheca virtuale
divenne pienamente operativa era
consultata da tutti frequentanti della
facoltà ce l'avevamo fatta sempre
sorprendente come esperienze tutto
sommato così piccole possono far virare
un'intera esistenza come una sinfonia da
quel primo movimento è scaturito il
secondo perché quello in fondo è stato
l'inizio di tutto
nella mia storia professionale certo ma
soprattutto del germogliare di un'idea
come mai mi è rimasta nel cuore
questa piccola storia due studenti che
decidono di utilizzare la tecnologia per
risolvere un piccolo problema
contingente perché ho visto cosa può
accadere quando la collisione creativa
fra più abilità viene messa al servizio
del bene comune
qualcuno diceva che l'innovazione nasce
dalla collisione di idee beh sottoscrivo
vi faccio un altro esempio prendete loro
queste due ragazze sono i soulwax e
ivano brian nel 2012 i soldi allora
studente di economia e commercio al
trinity college di dublino incontra even
che sta completando un master in scienze
ambientali parlando scoprono di
condividere l'amore reciproco per il
cibo e il disgusto per lo spreco
alimentare dovete sapere che un terzo
del cibo prodotto nel mondo diventa
spazzatura così nasce food cloud
l'idea di utilizzare la tecnologia
un'app per smartphone per rendere il
processo di raccolta redistribuzione
delle eccedenze alimentari scalabile e
sostenibile solo cinque anni dopo da
quell'incontro fu scout avrà già
recuperato più di 2.500 tonnellate di
cibo donate a 1.100 strutture caritative
in regno unito e in irlanda
perché in questi due casi la tecnologia
è riuscita a generare un impatto sociale
qual è la nota dominante di queste due
storie
io credo che la differenza sta tutta
nelle entusiasta partecipazione di un
manipolo di attivisti digitali il term
entusiasmo deriva dal greco antico
entusiasmo formato da anne in the host
dio e o usi a e senza letteralmente si
potrebbe tradurre con con dio dentro
dice in italiano normalmente sta
indicare più un sentimento di
appassionato interesse nei confronti di
un ideale o di una causa
ecco dal mio punto di vista
l'etimologia della parola entusiasmo è
quanto di più vicino possibile alla
definizione di attivista digitale un
attivista digitale è una persona
competente nell'uso di tecnologia il cui
entusiasmo nei confronti di una causa lo
porta a ricercare soluzioni per il bene
comune
gli attivisti digitali agiscono come
mediatori culturali hanno il compito di
portare dentro un progetto tecnologie
che altrimenti resterebbero fuori fuori
dai contesti fuori dalle specifiche
situazioni di bisogno come quelle
affrontate da me alyson oliver questo
processo di mediazione di trasmissione
di passaggio fuori dentro è la chiave
per rendere utile la tecnologia utile
perché al servizio del bene comune
una tecnologia diventa utile quando
viene situata ovvero plasmata attorno
alla specifica situazione viene adattata
allo specifico contesto per rispondere
ai suoi bisogni cloud connettività
intelligenza artificiale stampa 3d
internet delle cose sono solo alcuni
esempi di tecnologie che possono essere
portate all'interno portata all'interno
per sostenere lo sviluppo
dell'organizzazione della sua causa e
attivisti digitali fanno questo sono
come il radar in grado di scansionare il
meglio dell'innovazione tecnologica
disponibile e di sostenerne e l'adozione
nell'organizzazione a cui appartengono
spesso pensiamo agli attivisti digitali
come nerd che vestono felpe nere con
cappuccio e passano la loro vita dietro
allo schermo di un pc ma in realtà le
cose stanno ben diversamente
prendete lui daniel ben horyn dopo aver
discusso le esigenze tecnologiche delle
organizzazioni non profit con i membri
di uil
che era una delle prime community online
alla fine degli anni 80 daniel fondo a
compimento in seguito techsoup il suo
obiettivo è creare un programma in cui
coloro che avevano competenze
tecnologiche mentori si mettessero a
disposizione come volontari per
assistere le organizzazioni senza scopo
di lucro nell'utilizzo delle tecnologie
dell'informazione
a un certo punto da anni inizia a
sollecitare donazioni di prodotti
tecnologici soprattutto da riviste
specializzate che avevano grandi scorte
di software invenduto inviate a loro ad
aziende in cerca di copertura dei loro
prodotti con più mentre raccoglieva
queste scorte e le cedeva organizzazioni
non profit per una tariffa nominale 5
dollari a partire da questa iniziativa
techsoup cresce in tutto il mondo
fornendo donazioni di prodotti software
a organizzazioni in 236 paesi e fornendo
un risparmio totale di 14 miliardi di
euro in spese di un all'inizio del
programma di donazione nel 2002
parlando con daniel in spagna un paio di
anni fa ho capito una cosa fondamentale
non è che tu nasci artista digitale
attivismo digitale non è a quanto ne
sappiamo una proprietà genetica impressa
nel tuo dna una persona diventa un
attivista quando la sua affezione una
causa lo spinge a mettere le proprie
competenze al servizio della causa
stessa e la passione per una causa che
ti rende un attivista allora un
attivista scopre di essere tale solo
quando entra in relazione con un
contesto che lo stimolo a mettere il
proprio sapere tecnico a disposizione un
attivista digitale ha bisogno di una
causa per far sì che il proprio
entusiasmo si concretizzi nell'applicare
delle proprie competenze tecniche e
questa spinta sarà tanto più forte
quanto più sentirà che quella causa non
riguarda solo lui ma tutti tutto il
mondo come è successo a me con quella
bacheca appesa all'università come è
successo risolti poi venne con la loro
applicazione per il recupero del cibo
come è successo a daniel quando ha
fondato techsoup
lo scopo per il quale mette al servizio
le competenze tecniche è l'elemento che
ti rende un attivista digitale perché
non esiste nessun altra causa
in grado di mobilitare ispirare di più
di una causa orientata al bene comune di
una causa sociale
lo scopo fa tutta la differenza del
mondo in questo ambito
ecco dunque perché non può esistere vero
attivismo digitale senza il terzo
settore essenziali non profit
come sapete un'organizzazione non profit
è un'organizzazione che per statuto non
è focalizzata sulla realizzazione di
profitti ma nel generare un impatto
sociale reinvestendo interamente gli
utili che eventualmente si originano
dalla sua attività è qui che arriva al
cuore del mio discorso quello che ho
fatto è concettualizzare cosa succede
quando una persona tech competente
aderisce una non profit per sostenere la
causa sociale è probabilmente l'idea più
semplice del mondo io la chiamo il
cerchio della buona innovazione
abbiamo detto che un attivista digitale
è come un mediatore che porta tecnologia
in un contesto non profit al fine di
supportarne la missione massimizzare il
potenziale l'impatto di
un'organizzazione non profit significa
rendere più chiaramente evidente questo
ruolo sociale il ruolo sociale che a
questo si traduce in maggiori
probabilità di attrarre nuove risorse
che possano spingere lo sviluppo del
programma
a questo punto anche la disponibilità di
attivisti digitali si espande così come
la possibilità di utilizzare tecnologia
per aumentare l'impatto questo cerchio
continua ad autoalimentarsi fino a che
la continua contestualizzazione di
tecnologia non genera uno shock questo
shock è il momento in cui
l'organizzazione esplora nuovi modelli e
inizia a fare cose diverse non le stesse
cose di prima in modo diverso proprio
cose diverse
l'essenza dell'innovazione voglio
raccontarvi una storia che fa capire
benissimo questa concettualizzazione
da circa un anno faccio parte di un team
interdisciplinare che impiega vari tipi
di tecnologie per il supporto a terapie
svolte con bambini con disturbo dello
spettro autistico
in particolare ho aiutato a costruire
un'applicazione che consente di
aumentare l'accuratezza con cui vengono
registrati informazioni relative alle
terapie
l'idea di fondo è che avere a
disposizione dati puntuali consente di
migliorare le terapie da quando il
progetto iniziato
abbiamo registrato un imprevisto una
sorta di effetto hawthorne un
miglioramento delle performance dovuto
alla presenza di osservatori nel tempo
ha iniziato a un osmosi fra i membri del
team informatici hanno iniziato a capire
di più di terapia mentre i terapisti
sono addentrati nelle logiche di
sviluppo software
così la tecnologia si è arricchita per
mezzo di questa osmosi è diventata
progressivamente più accordata più
pertinente più capace di rispondere alle
esigenze del contesto
questo perché la tecnologia era
informata delle esperienze dei terapisti
che a loro volta avevano fatto evolvere
il loro approccio terapeutico integrando
componenti digitali così nel tempo
siamo arrivati ad avere il prototipo di
una soluzione veramente innovativa che
oggi possiamo proporre a tutti gli altri
terapisti in italia nel mondo e che si
occupano di autismo van un salto
quantico nell'orizzonte di questa
organizzazione non profit
entra qualcosa di completamente nuovo
l'accesso da una nuova scala di impatto
sociale cosa innescato questa
innovazione
ancora una volta come per la bacheca
digitale costruita in università
l'entusiasta partecipazione di un
manipolo di attivisti digitali emergenza
ambientale povertà alimentare educativa
crisi sanitaria
questi sono solo alcuni dei fronti in
cui c'è più bisogno di attivisti
digitali
si tratta di sfide cruciali che hanno
bisogno di una componente digitale per
essere affrontate e vinte
si tratta di sfide che hanno bisogno di
attivisti digitali
io credo che il progresso tecnologico
abbia un significato nella misura in cui
viene impiegato per il bene comune per
le persone parliamo spesso di codici di
interfacce di piattaforme ma dietro
tutte queste etichette ci siamo noi ci
sono le persone questo è il compito
dell'attivista digitale
forse spesso parlando di attivismo
digitale pensiamo solo a chi usa
internet ei media digitali per
influenzare l'opinione pubblica per
mobilitare le masse per gridare
attraverso i social ad esempio a un
cambiamento necessario
giusto per carità ma c'è anche altro
l'attivista digitale non è solo chiusa
il digitale come cassa di risonanza per
le proprie idee ma anche chi sceglie di
avvicinare umana e digitale e
facilitando quel processo virtuoso per
cui tecnologia persona iniziano a
suonare in armonia senza che l'una si
annichilisca nell'altra
ecco perché ciascuno di noi può essere
un attivista digitale questa cosa è
diventata particolarmente chiara da nove
mesi a questa parte
ad agosto 2020 è nato mio figlio luca
luchino per amici e familiari
da quando l'ho tenuto in braccio la
prima volta non riesco a smettere di
pensare una cosa temo che fra qualche
anno luca potrebbe farvi una domanda e
tu papà cosa hai fatto
se è stato sugli spalti a guardare
oppure se è sceso in campo hai cercato
di fare la tua parte al massimo delle
tue capacità ecco perché ho scelto di
essere un attivista digitale perché
spero che quando questa sua domanda
arriverà lui riesca a vedere che ciò per
cui oggi ci stiamo spendendo avrà già
fatto una differenza nel mondo generando
una nuova partecipazione e costruendo
una nuova democrazia
grazie